look at the green screen nonsense
happening on those glasses
see that there's like weird green screen
can we go back to look at our look at
our water on our green screen it's it's
pretty it's pretty solid yeah
ain't no weird artifacting happening
there awesome tex murphy
what was that noise
hello welcome to random encounter the
weekly live streaming show on
gamespot.com and twitch.tv four slash
game spot we play a different random
video game my name is daniel o'dwyer and
i'm joined by our resident tex murphy
expert benito gonzalez i guess that's as
close as i can get like to being an
expert at something tex murphy well
we're gonna play the tesla effect a tex
murphy adventure which i believe is
technically the
sixth game yeah the sixth game in the
series but the first two the first two
mean streets and martian memorandum
where i believe we're on like amiga
commodore it's messed up so i've never
played these games ever
but you've played the i started with an
instant killing moon yeah which i
thought actually until today i thought
that was the first one it's like the
first fmv one though yeah the first one
where
i think where like you start seeing what
the next few games are gonna start
looking like the rest of the games are
gonna look like there's like three of
them in a set was there and then the
last one that came out was 98. under
killing moon the pandora directive and
overseer and then this is the last this
is the next one after eight years or
some or more
years
we're getting old old man
so for those who don't know what the
hell tex murphy is
uh what's the what's the elevator pitch
on these bad boys okay it's a film
noirish
private investigator game so like the
first game i remember it was like a save
the world thing but you didn't know that
you were saving the world until later
right or somewhere in the middle
spoiling but it's really just like a pi
like investigator murder or
i forget how they i forget how they
introduce the beginning but that's
pretty much it you're a pi in san
francisco in the future yeah and
everything is green screen it's awesome
all right so let's jump right in there's
probably going to be quite a lot of
dialogue in this or we're going to keep
our goddamn mouth up yeah you know
you're you're asking people questions
and all that kind of stuff all right
really important are we casual or a
gamer
casual mode why these things will not
reveal sparkle hints
in-game hint system is not accessible
plus this may not be skipped let's just
do gamer then sure we can figure this
out what should our name be should we go
emma our space or should it be something
else your text murphy oh no this is your
profile this is just oh wow this is
interesting
all right
cause you're you're text murphy i'm text
murphy yeah i also hear that tex murphy
is
played by the guy who designs this game
no way yeah look it's on their ideal
page i forget the dude's name but he's
actually the like lead designer he's
been the same guy it's been the same guy
the whole time yeah and you can see he's
he's kind of aging is he a hoe
all right where am i
is this a dream
not quite movie then you're the and i
wish i knew what happened
that's right murphy
but now is not the time for you to be
here
there is a vast and malignant evil at
work on the earth and fate
for some reason that even i cannot
fathom
god to oppose it
why me i don't know i'm not where's god
talking to him
nevertheless your face morgan freeman
all right it's already weird
thank you to over seven thousand members
of the mutant league who's committed
sports contribute oh wow oh yeah that's
right there was a whole racism thing
about mutants
watch six wasps yeah because there's
mutants in the world and wait was that
was that thing about a kickstarter or
was that real i think that was real but
it might have been a kickstarter it
might have been a kickstarter but it
might have been a kickstarter thing that
brought it into the
game world you know what i mean they
they you know yeah okay yeah they've
integrated
all right
god this is epic
it's true no this is like the first deck
of murder under killing moon was the
first time i played a game that really
felt like i was playing a movie really
yeah how come it's taken him so long to
get back to this i was also like you
know 14 so i didn't have a very high
standard
look at this look at this this is like
some game of thrones nonsense
jody russell
that guy that's like a legit intro yeah
this is some
massive testicle on top of that
lighthouse or something
this is weird it feels like an hbo show
it does
although i bet it's probably closer to
something sci-fi
yeah which is good yeah sure
i don't want to skip anything i don't
want to skip any of this
look at that guy he looks twee as hell
he looks so sciency
much science yes gigglington the game is
out it came out yesterday last week or
last week twenty dollars on steam
june lockhart's in it
kevin murphy as smart alex
what
new san francisco what
let's go we could probably find we can
probably find the work work building
san
my francisco isn't in the vlog all right
i pip might be covering up these
subtitles lads mutant part of the city
close to coy tower awesome a place
they've been refurbishing like straight
up downtown
that's only like eight blocks away from
business crazy can we move the paper get
rid of it
i've cracked some pretty big kids dudes
you may even hurt me
but i don't do much investigating
anymore
these days i'm known for being a man who
gets things done no matter what the cost
wow you got a job that pays so he's like
now no questions asked
i can't really remember why this looks
way better
i'm guessing this [ __ ] didn't look like
this in 98 i know it didn't
or maybe because this is
legit good looking yeah like not just
video game good looking
there's others i'll watch the movie i'd
watch this movie
but even a set of principles can slowly
slip from your grasp the world has a way
of beating you into submission
circumstances change
the guilty aren't always punished
temptations become obsessions and love
can be violently taken leaving it empty
and hollow
each day innocence fades
your character weakens
and that's not all it wants but a piece
at a time until you can't be put back
together again
you finally realize the only way to get
ahead in this world is to make sure
you're on the winning side and then do
anything you can to stay alive
i don't know why i'm so reflective
tonight
maybe i finally crossed the rubicon but
that's not true either
i passed that sign miles back and didn't
even pause to take a picture
maybe i just feel extra guilty tonight
for what i'm about to do
it was a time when i would have never
agreed to do something that's despicable
i can't explain why i do this
but maybe judas would understand
it's like a it's like a b movie right
it's a game yeah a b game
the top window
i think we got it let's get out of here
try and shoot up techs
day one oh that's great
oh so there's a turnover you don't know
what happened
ouch
raised his head
san francisco is a dangerous place in
the future
i haven't been shot at yet here have you
in san francisco yeah no i have heard
gunshots have you many times yeah really
yeah goddamn
sunset not in the sunset over here out
in the bad parts of the mission and
whatnot
sean mckinnis lives out in the mission
and he has a fun game he likes to play
like on july 4th and stuff
oh no which is is it fireworks or
gunshots
i don't remember there being like a
airhead talking computer
might be wrong a long time ago your
personal assistant version 1.5 fashioned
three years ago in a factory with truly
horrible working conditions you don't
want to know i'm your trusty tech savvy
sidekick whose primary functions include
travel agent inventory tracking and
analysis investigative advice case notes
and i'm also accomplished
you gigantically irritating throughout
the entire game
would you like a tutorial on my usage
should we go tutorial or have you done
this um
i think you can skip the tutorial
tutorial just shows you how to use the
wheels you know how to use it i know how
to use that
look at that lady in the middle of the
loading bar hello hey weird looking lady
do you remember her
vaguely all right so now we're getting
video this is like the game proper okay
i love you've given me a 90 to 90 degree
uh viewing actually yeah you love
playing games in quake three stars i
like playing it in maximum field of view
if there's a 120 i'll take it
all right so i can right click on
anything you right click on anything and
that shows your option you can turn on
your flashlight
be like yo
i think we since we have gamer mode on
like on casual mode the stuff you shine
your flashlight on it'll shine if it's
like if it's something it's relevant but
if it's not i mean but we're playing
gamer mode so you're not going to see
that stuff
so the first thing you're going to want
to do is go to your desk and go behind
the desk and open up jars and look at
stuff all right like this is like the
this is how i started playing this game
like oh my god you can open all the
drawers there's stuff in all the drawers
and you can like investigate all that
stuff you couldn't do that before and
then though like back in the day when
this when you know games were coming out
back then it wasn't they were never this
deep
i've been able to achieve a certain
level of success ignoring all the rules
i'm guessing it wasn't voiced in the
past either yeah well no i think it was
that's why it was four cds oh wow that
was the first that was actually one of
the reasons i bought it it was like this
game is four cds it's gotta be good
four cds
xcom on the uh enemy unknown so what was
it called over here x ufo defense
um was that 12 discs on the amiga
yep 12 cds discs floppy disks this was
four cds jesus
what's that thing can i pick it up then
is that yeah
yeah i mean it'll show you you can pick
it up if you can pick it up the resort
sounds like an upscale condo community
definitely not something i'm interested
in
you have to look at resort by default
upscale condo um
yeah i had to open the one underneath
this to get to that one is this bright
enough yeah it's bright enough on there
all that stuff
oh i think
somebody's shouting at me might be your
phone glue is always useful that is true
adventure games you pick up anything
you're allowed to pick up yeah
what the [ __ ] is that i think it's the
phone
hmm no messages on the vid phone this is
the door
maybe that's just noise coming from
outside
i'm gonna go on my computer maybe
somebody's wiped my computer clean sons
of [ __ ] damn it on like episodes of
game of thrones on that
money what on earth is this amount of
cash doing in my office if someone was
trying to hire me to do something
probably wasn't legal
i better put this away until i know
exactly why it's here
fight it away in my pocket what's this
all right where's my inventory is it
here
what's the fact say
it's a note for my old friend archie
ellis
well that was stupid what did i do you
just read the note oh did i
do something with us no
it's a note from my old friend archie
ellis apparently he's out of town doing
some research when he returns i'll need
to ask him about the case we're working
on how long are these games generally
oh man
uh
long
i remember playing under kelly moon for
a while but mostly because i was bad at
it
and i also play on hardest difficulty my
camera books are great but
the big finish is so rich so much stuff
to like mess around like the world is
it's really been fleshed out because
it's like the sixth game so it's a fully
fleshed out world by richie haven's
signature guitar signature
she's one of my like
heroes actually oh really yeah
it's my jean autry fake book whenever
i'm feeling low
maltese falcon
i remember picking up this little suit
from your woody allen film how long was
i knocked out
i wonder how much this character is
based on like the designer's own tastes
and loves i wanted to i mean i'm sure
there's a lot of like yeah i'm
remembering
i was finishing up the latest adventure
and i realized i devoured several
chapters and it wasn't agreeing with me
i could feel my stomach churning like a
volcano and i realized i wasn't gonna
make it to the bathroom oh but
i'll get you murphy if he's the last
thing i do
yeah it's kind of been a sore spot in
our relationship ever since
yeah i remember that acting is always
has always been very like overdone yeah
it's almost theatrical yeah
and that's the first thing that really
got me into when i first played this
game there was one joke in the first
game that like immediately drew me in oh
yeah and like that was permanently
sealed as it opened directly into my
bedroom someday i hope to collect all of
the mike and i camera comics so much to
do here that's a side quest you got to
get all the mike and ike hammer comics
oh really yeah
and they all go up on this wall oh
that's cool
all right let's go outside yeah go check
out the world go talk to people this
game's about talking to people and then
it's all in fmv and stuff yeah so it
wasn't a horrible dream
they're gun shell casings and a shot out
window above the electronic shop
i know i'm involved but how
i should investigate the area and then
find out if anybody else heard the
commotion
that's who you want to skip yeah that's
cool
chelsea's newsstand is completely
abandoned
i need to find out what happened to
chelsea remember chelsea i do
i do
all right so let's uh let's investigate
the scene
where is he
he's over the window
yeah
ptsd
tesla invention
the strangest feeling this is related to
a case i was working on well the name of
the game is the tesla effect so
something looks like the dumpster
escaped unscathed motor oil the secret
ingredient to louie's armageddon blend
totally up at this time so this right
here this is the
you're just looking at stuff you're
finding clues so there's no evidence
there's no like
combat
like that no one knows these back alleys
of chand are quite like me
i don't think there's like combat
traditions taken from the top floor of
the electronics shop who's over there
spying on me so how often how much did
these games in the past like fall into
the trap of i'm playing an adventure
game i have all the pieces and i can't
put them together in the right way
like um i think this solved it because
this wasn't so much about gathering
items as it was about having the right
conversations with the right people oh
really and like inferring the right
information yeah
nice graffiti art
yeah okay i like the amount of like just
inconsequential yeah i like this i
actually love that in games i love it
when there's useless stuff in games to
sort of throw you off yeah
totally and like that's what a lot of
the early you know yeah skull ninja or
like
the useless things like in monkey island
the the
the wax lips like you never use them
yeah but like that was like one of like
three items in that game that you never
use you know even the rubber chicken
ended up being something you needed to
use yeah
is there another one how come another
mike and i came and this might be like a
candy cane
trail
yeah it looks like a breadcrumb trail
there's another one on the ground really
right there oh yeah it might
be a little bit candy comic citizen
candy cane
the knob
it's an electronic shop now but it once
was a boarding house for some of san
francisco's most notorious smuggler
these dumpsters have housed various
individuals i can't jump or anything
that's worth mentioning it's nice to
know i'll have a place to go if i can't
looks like louie at the bruins stew is
preparing to open up shop you should go
talk to him maybe he heard something
absolutely all right where's the bruins
jew what'd you say
louis the bruins stew was about to think
that's in the corner that's the diner on
there
let's go talk to someone i want to see
some of this
yeah
show them all my sweet comics i picked
up uh i remember right i think let's go
right there
ruin stew
i'm here to see my pal louie but i see a
pretty brunette this is like a recurring
character all right feeling she
recognizes me but i have no idea who she
is oh it's going to go into video now is
it
yeah
all right this is rod
wow hello stranger hey
hinge me this
totally feels like a dream
that has got to be the nicest thing
you've ever said to me just for that i'm
going to get you some coffee
i love how vague these are yeah
metaphor or less
how can i knock like that
sure
i like it like my heart
black
this is i love how weird this is uh
all right
so i say yes
literal i wonder does that mean like
red and
i don't know
buzzkill
i'm still trying to figure out what
they're actually what they actually mean
with these things all right i'm gonna go
buzzkill
oh man
ruin my joke
is that blood
oh hush
been out picking fights again
uh i don't know what happened but
you look pretty incredible
this is really weird
i do huh
you in the mood for a little
role-playing
who do you think you are
mr
tall
blonde
and bloodied
this is really weird
what the god the hell is going on
so usually in these situations i'd pick
the weirdest one
they're all weird
uh
stranger danger i don't i don't want to
ruin this moment
i gotta turn tables
you seem to know who i am
who are you
i'm taylor
and i'll be your nurse
i recommend two aspirin and lots and
lots of memories
i think she wants to get boned
i think boning is on her
uh
i have to investigate these gunshots but
maybe if i were to do it really quick
um
i have to go into work today
unfortunately
but maybe i have to work tomorrow
oh geez he's getting coffee in the
morning i got a new discussion at work
[ __ ] i'll send it to your smart house
see
you at the north hill clinic
call me after and tell me what she says
about that noggin of yours
see uncle louie i see you taylor
oh sorry it's louie's niece oh oh louie
you ain't looking too hard
he's uh he's a mutant okay are you doing
here
what are you doing here what have you
been doing since the goonies are they
like not friends now
her
hey tell me who that woman was who just
left here and why does she act like she
knows me why you gotta be like that
you know taylor
a little too well you asked oh oh oh he
burned his knees again
i told you look at the green screen
nonsense happening on those glasses
can we go back to look at our look at
our water on our green screen it's it's
pretty it's pretty solid yeah
ain't no weird artifacting happening
there awesome tex murphy
all right we should make a text murphy
game we should make a text murphy game
i see an episode of something
all right uh
i don't know i
feel like i just want to click on acid
trip
stone cold sober
other than my head
i feel totally normal
it's everything else that's weird
what happened to your head
i don't know
i woke up on the fire escape i go into
my apartment and everything is different
the street chelsea's newsstand you
everything is completely different oh
that's cool i mean i don't know whether
i'm tripping here or having a bad dream
or something
what's the last thing you remember
before you woke up
uh i don't know
something with chelsea
chelsea
what day do you think it is no hold on
what year do you think it is
what year are you serious
it's
40. oh [ __ ] he's been asleep for seven
years geez
holy [ __ ] look at that calendar over
there
on the fridge
2050.
what the hell's going on here
last night chelsea and i went to the
golden pagoda
oh wow that's the best that's the old
game wow
that's what they used to look like i
think that's probably over here this is
probably over here oh no
it's me
look
somebody has stolen our car
i mean here i am my speeder's stolen out
here i'm sitting on a great garage
boy uh would you guys like to live to
the cop shop
no we'll walk he's really just trying to
do us a favor chelsea i am getting a
really bad feeling about this it's like
some sort of date this is some this is a
really good way to do
a remake or like the next in the series
after a long time this is the way this
is some awesome fan service going on
here yeah
he's having a very bad day that true
text oh no everything's just going
peachy well things could get worse huh
oh what
he shot me he you shot bars he just shot
that woman in the neck
there's nothing
it's cold blooded why isn't there
anything that's what i'm trying to tell
you my i think i have to buy this game
yeah yeah it was seven years ago
what the hell is that oh man vampires
looks like you got injected with
something
wait
maybe that's what's messing with your
head
so have they not seen him in seven years
as well or yes like i think that's why
he was mad in the beginning
north hill clinic that's the doctor
that's the place that
his niece told you to go to right is she
gonna be there maybe oh
your niece taylor she said something
about a doctor at the north hill clinic
ah
kate donahue she's a friend of taylor's
she's real good
i'll bet she could fix you up this guy's
reminding me those skinless dudes in
fallout
yeah that's basically what it is
ghouls the ghouls yeah
what did i call people with skin in that
game again
skinnies or something yeah it's gotta
[ __ ] love falling yeah i love flying
relationship with taylor so what about
this woman taylor i mean she seems to
know me pretty well
that ain't none of my business knife
oh i thought he was the right guy for
her
but two adults can i bet he's still been
around for the past seven years but he
woke up this morning he just didn't
remember the last seven years yeah
you can't be driving in this condition
there's no way that girl tell you what
i'll call you into him that much i'll
have him wait till you're ready to go
what
what just happened oh what do you want
to ask him about oh wow okay okay
uh memory loss
i wish i could tell you everything you
can't remember
but i don't know much
you and chelsea went missing and then
you showed up out of nowhere a few weeks
later
a couple of days after
you was gone again okay i only saw you a
few times after that
a couple of years went by and then you
came back and
something bad had happened to you
i don't know what
but it made you hard and mean oh thank
god you just got worse
you got to where i didn't even want you
around anymore
not saying something because you're a
real piece of [ __ ] uh
a cup marcula you by the way smooth
skins smooth skins
thank you
uh
what should we ask about tex murphy
that's what i mean sure it's good to
have the old mice back
i don't want to get all mushy but
i missed you mike
this is weird this game is weird like
really into it uh chelsea you know she
in the game you like i love i don't
remember
this guy was really the only character i
truly remember
he was like a main character even
afterwards
all right one more question
ladder
i'm just intrigued
i don't got a ladder
you might want to check at the golden
gate while asking about a ladder they've
been doing a bunch of renovations all
right
great okay bye
i can't go to the north hill clinic not
now i need to investigate the crime
scene to find out what happened you
gotta investigate
all right so the story is starting to
get cold
should be preserved repairs are done for
a few months then the workers disappear
when city hall realizes what type of
people really inhabit this place what
neighborhood is this
this is
this is the financial right yeah being
part of that is this the fight is this a
happening sort of really helping my
midlife crisis where's the koi tower
that's quite tower there's court tower
so if we are on the
see there's buildings everywhere so i
can't tell where the bay is where's
transamerica
there what's up there's trans america
right there wait it's this guy no see
that thing peeking out the top back up
back up oh there right there yeah yeah
so the bay's behind us
if that's transamerica and that's quite
tower
we should be able to triangulate where
we are right
i think we need a third one the
triangulate
and it's trying let's look at maps you
look up that this is completely only for
people who give a [ __ ] about san
francisco once was a boarding house for
somebody i don't know if it's like right
are we just are we eddie
it's kind of looking tenderloiny to me
but
that's probably more to do with the
behind rooks pawn shop is a dirty ugly
alcove that reminds me a lot of rookies
this dude's face on this thing
oh i remember the day i came back to my
office to that grisly sight
flashback
a lot of flashback
to another
old tex murphy thing why is that
screaming old man's head in the jar of
water i tried for an hour to get pug's
head out of the water cooler but it was
no dice
the police showed up and thought about
grilling me until they realized pug was
a mutant and it was like they couldn't
care less
i guess people are a little apprehensive
about taking that bottle back for
deposit oh my god this is these
dumpsters have housed various
individuals over the years
there's quick tower there and there and
transamerica is somewhere here so we are
like around there we we are north of
broadway
uh what the hell is this thing
broken zip line yeah the zipline trolley
is broken oh it's missing a wheel can
you pick that up somewhere yeah just
there on the ground
wait can i equip that i know there's
this hand icon i guess i better not be
too creative because it won't work all
right i'm going to take out my so if we
were playing this on casual mode this
thing will be lighting up and that yeah
all just all the like actual inclusion
oh but i love that like so much
inconsequences like this dirt pile yeah
the city of old san francisco picks up
the trash has something to say about
everything i think we're getting close
to our date oh my god they pick up the
trash once a year there's the ladder
this is a really well realized
world even as someone who doesn't know
the old games yeah yeah like i feel like
i'm getting a lot out of this you feel
like it's an actual like inhabited world
yeah big time
this door is just pain
oh good go go back down i saw that
basketball hoop try to play basketball
real quick
over there
oh there's no ball oh there's the ball
yeah i bet you you can still do that why
was this a thing that was the first joke
that was the first joke that i gave you
killing me yeah it goes for a shot yeah
good try
see if it works
are you are you hoping there's going to
be some repeat humor happening it's the
same joke oh this door opens no the
gate's locked oh i gotta get it we gotta
solve a puzzle to do it so i'll check
back later looks gets back to work okay
okay
um was there any pointing up there i
wonder there's that empty window over
there but i feel like this is the wrong
side of the road so
i don't think they would open the
dumpsters no it just talks when i do it
um
so there's my office this is the
electronic shop that had the busted up
window so i feel like we should probably
probably need to get him i don't think
he can get in there though that's oh
that's why you need to get the ladder
right to get to the window right into
that window okay
yeah we've already been back here where
did he say
the letter was
oh yeah
the hotel
oh no
some random voice in the back of her
head has told us that it might be the
hotel what the hell is this
the fuchsia flamingo
good yeah cards to midnight
rusty's fun masks it's closed most
businesses on chandler avenue won't open
it oh yeah this is how they restricted
you before it was time of day right okay
yeah this is the hotel so wow
oh cutscene i think has been renovated
i guess that dumbbell ardo must have
come into some money you put her into
the game as i walk to the counter i
suspect this place the chatter into it
awesome i'm kind of
we saw this as a trailer on the lobby
when mary played it for new releases and
i wanted to play because it looked kind
of dumb
it's actually kind of great
i can see myself playing this
a bunch and it's really rewarding when
you solve mysteries yeah yeah
i just love how hokey it is you can
clearly tell that the people who've like
made this game are so into this yeah you
know they're not trying too hard you
know i mean they're they're just having
fun with it
mr murphy
holly graham
holly graham
oh nice
nice
flattering comments wow
service around here has gotten a lot
better and a lot smarter
call me tex
no thank you the last time i tried that
you were all i'm a professional you
should be treated as such that's awesome
management heard about it and i didn't
get any time off for a month
that was not confusing what do you mean
last time i was here this is the first
time i have seen you
so there's probably a bug in your system
or something you're the one with the bug
right up here you know what oh my penis
uh get acquainted so
you got a name
you know very well who i am holly graham
cute right
intangibles just can't resist a pun
tangibles
that's so cool that's like the smooths
yeah the smooth skin that's what the
holograms call humans
tangibles
spell check humor
so
i think your sign has a typo it says
holograms are people too
so you can read it it's for the hologram
rights movement oh it's that's the spit
on this one it's holograms holograms
aren't people what was it mutants before
yes
that's exactly what they used to say
about minorities women and mutants it's
our turn now i'm officially on strike oh
this is great
well i support you 100
i believe everybody deserves equal
treatment
really
the last person i thought i'd hear that
from
everyone in this neighborhood's afraid
of you you know
i'm terrified
see the thing is i want to be nice to
her but i don't know which one's going
to be the next one but then maybe that's
the fun part of this is that
you're not really playing you're not
playing you you're playing text yeah
yeah so like these are the things tex
would say what do you want him to say
uh
it101
i think your file on me might be
corrupted mind if i ask a few diagnostic
questions
sure though i should warn you i don't
get out much
great ladder please keep everything like
that over at the snow white warehouse
so i so what i think happens is like
what you choose in the wheel
will probably determine what you get to
ask her right okay yeah
oh you know me
just a hologram
here to serve my tangible oppressors
is this slightly out of focus as well i
think her face might be out of focus
just a coming from a video
now that i know you support the hologram
rights movements
i may have to re-evaluate those i think
it's more that like the backgrounds are
rendered so they're super sharp and like
the contrast between the sharpness and a
regular camera
uh louis the nicest tangible i've ever
met see
you can see the spill too yeah
i've heard they keep a key or something
to get inside the warehouse by the door
right oh there you go thank you
uh
well it's no golden gate hotel is it
golden gate hotel is there going to look
around the hotel
if there's anything here that could help
me out
okay something in the lobby i feel like
yeah i got my flashlight
visiting salt lake
be sure to visit oh
oh wow you saw like
gone or something
hopefully ballroom renovations include
installing an actual ball pit
forget it jake it's a chinatown sale
you know when you listen to like a
comedian as one of those old-timey
comedians yeah and you wouldn't really
find them funny but there's like a part
of you
like a charm there's a chart yeah like
i'm getting that off this like i don't
find a lot of this i wouldn't find like
overtly funny but
i don't know i've been charming but
you're not yeah but you're not like oh
that's not funny this is stupid yeah
it's not stupid not funny it's just like
it's just kind of cookie yeah hokey and
it's kind of cool i like it
all right we're gonna take a break okay
we're gonna take a break we'll be back
in
about 30 seconds uh stick around we've
got more uh tex murphy
tesla effect tesla effect has better say
tex murphy nonsense but this game is
ending with nonsense really into this
all right see you in a minute
welcome back to more tesla effect a text
murphy adventure which came out on steam
last week
for 20 bucks uh sixth in the series
first game it's come out in 16 years in
the tex murphy franchise and uh yeah
it's uh it's real fun we're outside the
llama club here snow white warehouse we
believe has a ladder
so it's just a case of finding this key
she was talking about um but where did
you say this somewhere outside the door
there needs a key that's where you put
the key
there it is there you go what do we got
here
it's like instructions to get into the
snow white warehouse awesome all right
the code four two six seven eight
eight
yeah it needs a key i need to find the
code
thing okay
see what it said again did it say
anywhere change the snow white warehouse
lock box so there's a lock box that has
a key in it okay
oh is this like a musical cues it's a
force field oh thing this is very
half-life 2-e oh so that's the border
yes you can't go faster
i don't know what it is
there's something scary in the sewers
like
inconsequential dialogue this became a
highly sought after neighborhood post
world war three when it was found that
the radio couldn't penetrate through all
the lead paint oh that's amazing
that's correct this became a highly
sought after neighborhood post-world war
i didn't go anywhere the radiation
couldn't penetrate through all the lead
now this is very fallout 4
going into old
irradiated houses
oh hello
most likely to become an enforcer for
the mafia
i bet these are like the developers or
something yeah that's probably looking
at a movie premiere or like they're
familiar with the pose in front of the
leather-bound books i wonder if it's the
folks who were like play is that text i
wonder if that's well the shirt says
audrey hepburn and those legs are all oh
wow look how many there are i wonder if
this is like oh it might be the
kickstarter dudes
oh that's probably it yeah
these are like one of the the stretch
goals or one or one of the the what they
call them
one of the country yeah levels yeah
that's so cool i like that they've done
it
seems to have done a really good job on
this stuff oh there's another one comic
it's a mike and i camera candy comic
right licorice rope
it's always really satisfying even if
you're not a fan of a series to see what
somebody does right by
a re-release yeah because it happens so
little and yeah there's so many series
that so many people would like to see
come back i mean i think i'm pretty sure
that's a consequence of this being
kick-started right like it's the fans
who paid for this game so yeah it's
funny how that works isn't it it's like
it means
you know contrast that with something
with like thief or deus ex which
you know they try to reinvent yeah for a
new audience and then it sort of you
know inevitably takes it takes away from
what the stuff that people enjoyed from
the first one
and it doesn't necessarily mean it's a
bad game but it just doesn't scratch the
nostalgia itch that those other ones did
is anyone in the chat know what the
lockbox says
i find it weird that that's not the
actual that there's another layer to
this clue that it's not just there needs
a key it's locked and i need to find a
way to open it that's the snow wide
warehouse
lock box
i don't think anybody knows that's the
snow white warehouse
most businesses on chandler avenue it's
like a swipe card reader
i'm a club
checker in this building one more time i
wonder if you can get around them around
the back by axe by getting in through
there
it's worth a look
that's always the thing i find weird
about playing these types of games on
streams as well is that
i feel people getting impatient yeah
but but it's like the plotting nature of
it i remember playing the secret of monk
island for the first time and
especially the beginnings of these
adventure games where you're kind of
like a fish out of water and you're just
like flailing around
i think i think the first one got it
took me like a summer to complete like i
was probably eight or something or nine
but still like
and it didn't matter yeah like that's
just kind of how those games work i
remember back then like i played king's
quest one like for hours and four days
and i never finished it i was never
actually trying to play the game i was
just walking around typing stuff into
the thing like push the rock oh that's
so awesome
so like we were talking about with greg
i guess in the lobby about like do you
ever worry that like that type of
fascination you had about games back
then where everything was new yeah
you're worried that you kind of you
might be able to replicate that again
yeah i mean i guess that's what like vr
is trying to do and all that new
technology
i've been playing a game i played a game
last night that is sadly under embargo
so i can't talk about it my god this
would be awesome on the oculus oh god
this is exactly the kind of game you
want to play on the oculus if they did
like 3d versions of the conversations
it'd just be weird when they're doing
those bits because you'd be looking at
your own character that's true
oh keeper says the key is in the hotel
oh really
okay maybe there's a lock box in the
hotel
i didn't realize the i guess the
warehouse is you probably have to go the
way i have to get the combo and then
back to the hotel to open the box for
some reason i did not assume that the
hotel and warehouse were
connected but of course they are because
the ladder so
you go in here only guests of this hotel
are allowed entrance through here i'm
guessing a lockbox would be somewhere
behind the receptions
i'll ask her let's see
how's your case progressing
do you know about the lock box
ask about the warehouse again
i've heard they keep a key or something
to get inside the warehouse by the door
by this door
oh she must have met them
nice
when visiting salt lake so when visiting
a beautiful song
on the table
oh san francisco
it's a key to a lock box
what we have a code and a key so
god this is confusing don't we have a
code into a lock box already
there's the key oh oh oh right okay the
key opens the box
okay there you go that's how that works
wow this where this is the most highly
secured warehouse i've ever seen in my
life
usually they just leave it open and pay
some stooge to sit in there and drink
coffee all night but okay i see that
jan's having a conversation about like
the old
uh
the old texas murphy games
and ulti
was asking if it looked like doom and it
didn't it actually looked like this but
extremely low res
the window was like that the top like
fifth of your screen and everything else
was ui
four two six eight i really appreciate
like deus ex one style that i had to
open that yeah i had to do that like
thief we did this
and then i actually have to press the
button
four two six eight i like that too
oh wow oh yeah okay
they should have used the uh
the do three
finger or cursor is still one of my
favorite things you just walk up to
um
computers and your eye
line would be that is still one of the
best like ui things i've ever seen
it's creepy wow is this still here
i use this to deal with a cunning
criminal on my under a killing moon case
who had a bad case i think we've got a
flashback here
look at that mustache it's so
is
i already had my name tattooed on his
knuckles and he wants to show me
firsthand when he gets joyrock 101
remembers this which game was that from
the chandler avenue they said that was
under killing movies
okay
oh that's great all right we need our
friendly the flashlight all right so
ladder cannot be that small
there it is is that it yeah all right
upstairs
if these areas are totally possible but
i also feel if they had any strong art
direction
it would really conflict with the
the jank of the fmv stuff maybe
that's the power
oh nice just bring the ladder down
typewriter looks like an interesting
read
x murphy had
it's an oh it's a next text murphy novel
oh brilliant
looks like an interesting read
it's so meta
yeah i wonder if he's like in a coma or
something this is why all this
flashback stuff this is a dream
is that enough now that i have a ladder
i can get into the second floor of the
electronic shop
complete disregard for inventory
i like it yeah carrying a ladder i offer
that letter my backpack
got one of those hermione bags he just
fills it full of his kind of bag of
holding
exactly
did you ever see those bags with bags
yeah
every comic-con
i go to that table i'm like i'm gonna
buy this bag and i ask him how much it
is and he says forty dollars i'm like
nah yeah forty dollars
there's graffiti
all right let's see if we can
well that was stupid
all right what do i have to interact
with too i'm no detective but you need
to find a way to get up to the second
floor
look at that and hit it yeah and
wait
oh jesus that matters
oh the old 90s game way yeah straight
through the wall
yeah louie once told me these rooms were
used by bootleggers and smugglers during
prohibition there were hidden panels in
rooms where they'd hide their stash
lives here is that a comic
and that's a damn shame this guy was
working diligently to get a free stuff
at inspector burns
you
oh so no more alcohol
huh
is that why that place is a coffee shop
oh yeah was that a barbecue it used to
be a bar oh wow
i don't remember if that was it no not
that place that place was always a
coffee shop okay but there is a bar
ding ding
watch
oh i can interact with it
you betting on a horse oh this must be
some sort of get oh like a mini game am
i supposed to be
following the oh is it simon says i
think it is
blue purple
this guy yep
this guy yep green yep top one yep and
then i don't i'm not exactly oh i can't
remember which i think it's this one
that one yeah the back says yes
yeah
[ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] this
i wonder what you win
yeah you're right you probably do have
to do it to win something yeah uh for
the sake of
the strange sake of stream sanity we're
not going to try to finish it let's keep
going
that shouldn't have been fun but it was
like this game is really
you feel like you're inhabiting the
world you feel like you're there yeah i
mean like you really feel like you're in
the world
oh yeah because everything is
interactable
we clearly have to do that thing to like
access an area or something that's not a
mini game all right that's a true puzzle
see the funny thing is we've got the
stream with a 60 second delay so this is
actually pretty easy well that's true i
could just what yeah how about i'll
remember the first
four
you remember everything after okay okay
okay okay
so i'm gonna go
purple yellow
okay it goes two three four oh [ __ ]
really yeah oh sorry so now it's just
three
it's about when we get to like the six
is my guess yeah so i'll do this three
you do the other one so i'll do that
okay
okay
12
and o'clock that guy
oh [ __ ] was there another one after that
you [ __ ] [ __ ] i think it's this one i
think it's this one
okay good good okay i'll do the first
three
okay i think i got it
it's six o'clock this guy yeah twelve
o'clock
like 3 15. oh
was that wrong yeah [ __ ]
oh is that it was that one that one all
right i've lost my one's name i think
what was after 12
wait let's watch the chat let's watch
this real quick
it's
that one that one that one this is so
cheating yeah
top one there we go three o'clock three
fifteen okay
this guy yep
please let there not be another one
all right there you go
winner and there you go whoa
there's a dude with no pants on
don't don't shoot
walk dead around where he's fighting the
gun at least
so theatrical but like yeah
i think it's like it's a lot of cartoony
yeah i mean it's very cartoony
trapped
oh finished day one well at the end of
this day i got to
have sex with that coffee girl so
sure so it only goes up from here
thanks gets his mojo on or
wait you get to pick which chapter you
play next
oh no because at the first one it had an
aura as well oh so maybe it's oh so like
how you do it yeah
right
smart alex had a point but i wasn't
gonna let him have the satisfaction of
knowing so
there was one good thing about spending
hours stuck in a laser net you've got
time to think who is this guy who killed
him
what kind of surveillance was he doing
right across from my apartment
and what's in the metal canister
have seven years really passed without
me remembering it is it related to my
head injury or the injection mark on my
arm
oh
you recognize this guy
he recognizes text though yeah
is he dead
well
i think you missed a hell of a party
party
yeah you're here in time for the laser
show
i wouldn't do it
i was here to meet carlos maldonado is
that you
or him
look i just stumbled onto this little
nightmare and i need to find out who
this guy was and what he was doing i'm a
pi
and i assume this guy is maldonado
my name's murphy
who are you
mason said maldonado was a pi
were you working with mason too i'll be
honest i don't know if i was working for
mason or not
actually
i'm having severe memory problems here
so anything you can tell me about
maldonado or mason or what's in the cryo
chamber here would be greatly
appreciated
i think i set up an alarm when i came in
here to use the ladder that was outside
i was just trying to help mason
he said come in here
find the pi
get the cryo chamber and keep it safe
hey hey hey i i found that first
slow learner
you have to find mason i think he's in
big trouble with bad people i don't know
why he's a neurologist for god's sake
but you have to promise
yourself
come after me
oh i promise my fingers are so frozen i
can't cross
if your memory problems are part of all
this mason is the only one who can help
you so you need to find him and bring
him back safe just as much as i do
thanks buddy i'll be in contact soon
he never said his name right no didn't
say who he was
i'd be terrified to be in that laser
tube yeah he fell asleep
he couldn't sit down how do you how do
you feel close i don't want to leave
this place without games i better hurry
up and find something before they get
here hey dead guy
tough break hombre
this sob has been living up here
watching my every move
they sent something it's a note from
mason
that thing on top of it
so that might come in handy
strictly speaking i would never
encourage anyone to break the law but
not even one creative mixers all right
well we got on this thing it was a
memory stick yeah
one terabyte flash drive yeah baby the
future is beautiful
nice to meet you actually not that far
from that no anymore
probably some ancient [ __ ] for those
guys
uh all right that's uh let's have a look
we're almost on our hour anyway so it's
coming out
escape down the ladder we finished the
first day two officials waiting to greet
me what we finished the first day yeah
did you just call
it i got a ladder
hello boys well
if it isn't tex murphy
what were you doing i think that guy was
about five years old
it's a little hard
you know the drill
i was really trying to get my hands on
that surveillance equipment
maybe i could see exactly what happened
to me i want to look at the kickstarter
one
if that's the case i feel sad for not
contributing
san francisco is our home
be a part of the solution to crime
immediately
like on our way to blade runner times
yeah
make it quick murphy i got about a
million things to do i say that's more
of the kickstarter
maybe not that guy but
like old guys from old times
did it you here to turn yourself in
the commissioner why is it
climbing the ranks
damage
i hardly recognized you what been 10
years
you were still a patrolman back then
i'm surprised you remember me
danwich are you kidding me rhymes with
manwich
man witches are unbelievable delicious
in case you didn't get the memo i head
up the department now
and things aren't as loosey-goosey as
they were under mauldin
why is it new san francisco the old one
fall in world war three or something i
don't know maybe like there was a big
one and we lost half the city i don't
know yeah i got it oh yeah
that's ominous
you think i came down here to turn
myself in i don't even know we just
found you at a crime scene with a dead
body
that has that been a constant thing in
the back of your head
or like i mean because the brain is
delivered
it's the same thing
like a hurricane yeah or some such yeah
man
yeah i grew up in a very boring part of
the world for that sort of stuff
drawing a blank
the name maldonado means nothing to me
and i insist that you give me a
polygraph test to prove it
i was just reviewing your file when you
came in
that screen is awkward because it means
you can't see me because it looks like a
lot
august 2047 washingtonis
nsfpd informant
beaten and hospitalized after providing
information about texas it's already the
past to us refuses to identify as
assailant
never to be seen again is this it maybe
it's
interesting
oh look it up the imdb
in the past few years you've gained
quite a reputation for yourself you've
got new san francisco's criminal
underbelly running scared
you're a cop is isn't that the way you
like your criminal underbelly we arrest
criminals so they could be tried in a
court of law we don't just kill them and
i won't tolerate vigilantes
if you didn't kill maldonado
what were you doing there
uh
i was awoken by gunshots i was just
trying to find out what was happening
i followed the trail and saw that
maldonado had surveillance equipment
aimed at my office
i want to find out what he recorded
who cares what he recorded
if you're such an upstanding citizen
you've got nothing to hide right
there's a secret
i wanted to find out whether he caught
me scrapbooking if that gets out i'm
throwing this down
i don't even think you're joking about
that you're free to go murphy
for now
any questions
it is that's him yeah
that's nancy after imdb research
he is indeed the soup nazi that is
awesome
i'm not sure what to think of you murphy
is there a question i can ask that
relates to soup justice can i request
soup
no justice for you
oh that's the neighborhood seems to
attract more than its fair share of
trouble
all right
i think we're done yeah i think we're
done here at the end of the stream here
encrypted members
probably have something
all right that was awesome fun if you
could help me break it then i'd be
impressed i really enjoyed that so uh
yeah that was your first tex murphy
experience right yeah
i really
i was uh surprisingly into that it was
um
pi raising current path i don't know i
was expecting some
jank and there is like a fair amendment
yeah there's so much self-aware of it
and the storytelling has done pretty
well you know the storytelling's pretty
good well written i felt like it was a
world that was like beyond considering
how like small that little area they
were letting you play in was i felt it
felt like a world that was beyond its
borders it kept going yeah yeah uh as
somebody who had played the old games
and was clearly getting some nice little
stardom yeah do you think you're gonna
play this i think i'm gonna actually i
wanna see i wanna know how long it is
first because i don't want to put too
much time into it but i think i i want
to give it a shot and i want to play
some days probably let's stop some
mysteries uh let's look it up on steam
uh as we tend to do
here on uh here on random encounter uh
just hit the start page oh really where
links oh yeah bam
full screen there i just hate using
steam's ui it's like it always yeah
uh tesla effect tex murphy adventure
tick tick yeah there you go it's uh
1999. let's check out the trailer
actually see if there's any other
private investigator in the big city
oh steam
murphy
uh awesome how are people finding it i
wonder actually you know what just in
case of spoilers that's not a book uh
yeah 1999 there's a big massive lady
beating him up um avail is it just pc i
always like when these ones are on mac
it is it's on mac as well so i might
play it out on my my little macbook and
see what happens
uh awesome
is there reviews yeah check out the we
don't usually do this but
i'm just curious i also kind of feel
like this is a really hard game to
review outside of the
like nostalgia like outside of being a
fan of the series yeah all right 70 out
of you know what 70 is
considering what genre this game is and
how reviews are written that's pretty
great yeah not bad and like a user score
of 8.6 nice yeah all right that's cool
thank you very much everyone benito
thank you very much for hanging out sure
thank you
and it wouldn't have been the same
without you this is a very much a game
that you need somebody with nostalgia
hooks to kind of let you know about it
uh don't know what's on next week in the
show as ever at daniel on twitter if you
have any suggestions and thanks for
hanging out see you next week bye